I was born in Leesburg Virginia and I've
actually lived there for 14 years until
I moved to a place called Alexandria
Virginia which is right outside DC so
sort of just been hanging out in one
state for my entire life and I now go to
the University of Virginia and I've
taken a little bit of time off to do
YouTube
right when clash of clans came out I
knew it was going to be such a
successful game even though it was
really in the infant stages and only had
maybe 5,000 likes on Facebook I know
after I played for two days and I texted
my friends who are at their schools I
said you guys have to download this game
this game's gonna be big so we all got
together we're all in our clan
there's games look like cut the rope and
stuff like that that you play for fun
while maybe you're waiting for five
minutes but I never really seen a game
like clash on mobile Age of Empires was
one of my favorite games growing up and
you sort of build your town and your
village and right when I downloaded
clash I got that feel that I'm
progressing I'm building my village and
that's what made it so addictive I've
been playing it I think for two weeks in
the game and been out for maybe a month
and I was looking for single-player
level maps online to see if someone had
done a walkthrough and I had no
experience with YouTube whatsoever
besides looking at cat videos and stuff
like that so I saw that no one had done
the levels and it was something I was
interested I was like oh I could do some
single-player guides and then slowly the
community said hey we want to see some
multiplayer battles and even though I
was new at the game it was fun to make
content fun to interact with the
community and just keep like making
friends I made my giant clan system from
there and then the game just exploded
and then from there a lot of other
youtubers came around and now it's been
fun being able to travel do clash of
clans stuff and a bunch of different
cities going up to Finland to visit the
supercell headquarters which is amazing
every single time and I've had an
awesome time
I think I had maybe one subscriber after
the second day and I remember telling my
friends and I told my friends I knew
they were messing with me because one of
them was a subscriber like I didn't
believe that people were actually
subscribing to my YouTube channel let
alone watching my videos I saw clash
grow as a game and then mic my channel
obviously grew with that as well as the
other people that started making YouTube
videos with me so right now I think I'm
at 1.1 million subscribers on my channel
and I know there's a lot of other
channels that are growing above a
hundred thousands so it's really
starting to like make an amazing
community on YouTube and it's something
that really mobile gaming hasn't seen
before